[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bienvenue pour le 7-8 une heure
en direct pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale si vous nous
rejoignez entre 18 et 19h et voici tout
de suite les principaux titres de ce 20
février les titres en images les parents
se sont pressés le nombreux pour
découvrir l'école des petits bilan une
qui va bientôt débuter ses activités sur
la commune d'el en cours une structure
qui permet aux enfants d'apprendre des
notions d'anglais dès leur plus jeune
âge être mécène à versailles ce n'est
pas simplement en financer la
restauration de monuments ou permettre
l'acquisition d'oeuvres d'art l'on peut
aussi aider la création artistique un
cercle de mécènes existent pour l'opéra
royal de versailles
il vient de s'ouvrir aux petites
entreprises le salon de l'agriculture
ouvre ses portes ce samedi un salon
toujours très populaire et qui fait la
part belle aux yvelines en vedette cette
année lorenzo un bélier mérinos de 85
kilos provenant de la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet vous le voyez prêts à
défiler et des élèves du lycée
professionnel henri matisse attrape
invités à participer à un atelier d'arts
plastiques atelier mix'art qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'un concours à vocation
internationale ce sera à découvrir tout
à l'heure et puisque nous sommes
mercredi
le mercredi c'est le jour de la page
culture avec aurélia de bissy bonsoir et
commence à wilfrid et vous invitait ce
soir et vient nous recevrons trois
experts donc spécialiste du cinéma et
chacun d'entre nous parleront de leur
programmation originale et puis nous
aborderons également la thématique du 35
mm puisque c'est la fin de la projection
à partir de bobines et c'est l'arrivée
du tout numérique le tout numérique l'a
finalement emporté voilà une page qui va
se tourner et on en parlera tout à
l'heure en seconde partie d'émission
avec vous nous passons pour l'instant
aux faits du jour versailles bon élève
c'est l'association des paralysés de
france qui le dit
[Musique]
l'association des paralysés de france la
pf qui a rendu public son baromètre de
l'accessibilité 2012 96 villes testées
parmi lesquels versailles le chef lieu
du département qui figure à la 26e place
une progression de 23 places non
seulement un an
48e en 2011 la municipalité a décidé de
faire des efforts pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite ou malvoyantes
c'est aussi une obligation légale depuis
2005 et la loi sur le handicap nous
avons contacté aujourd'hui la maire
adjointe en charge des affaires sociales
à versailles
corinne des ben écoutez la la première
mesure fait effectivement le plan
pluriannuel de mise en accessibilité de
la voirie des bâtiments publics et des
écoles
nous avons également mis autour de la
table tous les acteurs en fait de la vie
de la cité
les transports en commun ces bus le
château de versailles
l'université les grandes écoles que nous
avons pour donner bien sûr les services
de l'éducation que ce soit élémentaire
ou secondaire la trinité que nous avons
c'est la poursuite de la mise en place
de la mission accessibilité avec deux
objectifs prioritaires c'est la
sensibilisation de la population
être en mesure d'accueillir le handicap
quel qu'il soit
donc ça ce sont des actions de
sensibilisation la première que nous
avons fait en fin 2012
c'est de sensibiliser mille enfants à
découvrir ce que c'était 4 en situation
de ces sites et de fauteuils de surdité
aux mêmes de manque de compréhension
devant une problématique la deuxième
priorité ça va être deux établir en fait
un recensement de tous les acteurs qui
apporte aujourd'hui une réponse aux
personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap sur le territoire versa et 26e
ville sur 96 au classement accessibilité
handicap avec une note de 14,3 sur 20
premières villes grenoble avec 18,4
nous reviendrons sur ce sujet sur la
question de l'accessibilité dans les
villes dans notre édition de lundi dès
18 heures